alright guys I'm going to show you a
video of me uploading a high-definition
video to YouTube so first thing you do
make your video I happen to use
camstudio to make mine then opened up
Windows Movie Maker and I want to import
me in here to make my video this one is
gone I uploaded it alright it's done
it'll be in if you're using camstudio it
will be in your Program Files camstudio
going to find it
import and it'll be there pretty quickly
give it a sec alright here it is
umm I have no transitions of different
frames or anything so I'm just going to
drag it to right there that is it no
intro that's just it'll show up in a
preview what I want to do now is publish
the video so you can go file publish
movie ctrl P or just close movie here
Publishing it to my computer I will call
it my arrow snap tutorial hopefully this
will work in high definition
I selected more settings instead of best
quality which is by default and I said
Windows Media Player HD 720p 5.9
megabytes per second very good quality
and it's in 1280 by 720 which is perfect
for YouTube HD other resolutions are
include these right here 640 by 360 900
by 600 1088 by 6 12 and 1280 by 720 so
I'm going to publish that and I'll pause
the video and bring it back when the
movie is done publishing just a few
minutes but it's worth the wait
so here we go alright we're almost done
here instead we have about 50 seconds
remaining button it to fast forward I
will pause it again come back right when
we finish so give a sec right it has
finished publishing movie as you can see
it says remove happen published now what
this does is it puts the file on in your
my computers through my my videos folder
on your for my pal your computer can't
talk today
and it saves it in a 1280 by 720
resolution which is perfect for watching
them on YouTube so wow I don't know
putting movie when I click finish
because I know what I'm doing here
finish and you can visit this without
saving it because we just saved it and
I'll show you exactly where it is it's
in Marcus which is me here and in my
videos there it is is my ear snap story
so when you're done with this open any
internet browser I'll use Safari this
time open up obviously you probably know
these final steps if you've used an
account before choose a video file
you're uploading a video file and choose
the file you will find them in Program
Files
scroll to camstudio and select and open
your arrow snap tutorial that's the
button that says upload video and it
will start uploading an avi which is
exactly what you want so I'll type in my
title and it is as you can see uploading
I will bring these right back when it is
completed this will usually take a few
minutes it's not going to be instant and
take a few minutes depending on the size
the length of your video so we'll come
back when it is done also I just want to
show you when you're done actually
typing in all your information for the
title description etc about the video
hit the Save Changes button it will
continue to work on the uploading as you
do that so I'll be back in a minute
success this is what it looks like when
your tutorial or your video in HD avi
format is successfully saved and
uploaded okay I'm going to go to my
videos right now just to see it is there
and it will say at first for the first
few minutes it will say uploaded and
processing please wait when it is done
it will say life like all the rest of my
videos
live by the way subscribe so you can get
I'm making videos like crazy right now
this is an avi format don't expect when
it plays it's not going to first have
when you first get the video it's not
going to first have this watch in HD
link it's just going to be in terrible
quality for a little while but after a
while you'll get the watching HD link
and you can watch it in full YouTube
1280 by 720 a high-definition format so
it's a really really cool feature and
I'm going to make the rest of my
tutorials um this is pretty much all
that I can show you uh if you follow
those steps you should have a number of
options I'll go over them again for camp
studio when you're actually recording
these videos you should have the you
should have the DivX codec the Dybbuk
six point eight point five codec you're
going to want to have it on 100% quality
and again check auto adjust and drag it
to as close as you can 30 frames per
second and figure it to the 720 HD
profile which makes perfect sense
um and I use my region at right now I'm
using 1280 by 720 of course I mentioned
before you can always use one of the
following resolutions let's do it to you
earlier in the video
you know pause it take it down that's
what it is so yeah enjoy your
high-definition videos thank you
subscribe peace
you